As far as relationships are concerned,
there's three main categories of relationships in UML.
There are dependencies, depicted by dashed lines with an arrowhead,
indicating that the class at one end uses the class as the other end.
The solid lines without arrowheads are associations.
And that says that class at one end affects or
has a instance of the class at the other end.
The solid line can be adorned with a diamond.
The diamond is used indicate this has a or
aggregation embellishment to the association.
Third main category relationship is the generalization relationship.
The class at one end is a kind of a class at the other end.
In this case there is a solid line but it has that triangle at the end of it.